tout juste inauguré les dernières
finitions achevé le centre commercial de
keating découvre son nouveau visage
il compte désormais 40 magasins de plus
une surface de galeries x 4 est un
nouveau venu le grand kitty on sait bien
que ça ses cours de la 16
très bien
les cours ce matin les nouveaux magasins
aux seuls invités
outre mais là
ceci nous on est un peu d'aujourd'hui et
jojo on se croirait au magasin c'est
super c'est super vraiment très porteuse
varices héros super vraiment vraiment
très bien ma femme a dit qu'elle
reviendrait parce que moi je passe très
vite devant les boutiques de vêtements
revient tout seuls 300 personnes ont
travaillé sur le chantier durant deux
années 150 emplois ont été créés
répartis entre les commerces la
direction la gestion et l'entretien du
centre ce centre bâti autour du tout
premier hypermarché à planter dans la
région dijonnaise d'élever des licences
le sens commercial date de 1968 et il
était temps pour un hypermarché à ses
avants
les tanks de l'étonnement de mettre une
gare éléments qui corresponde
des leaders soit zone et opérant sur un
champ dijon on n'est pas véritablement
en concurrence avec toison d'or nous
occupons un lieu géographique et
différence sur une agglomération le
grand gué tenir face à la toison d'or
pas la peine de chercher rien ne figure
dans la mythologie ici la légende est
une réalité
l'idée par une économie rude et sans
pitié un combat de titans